justement c'était il ya un an 2 octobre
2020 la tempête alex ravageait
l'arrière-pays niçois quelle est la
situation sur place aujourd'hui comment
tenir compte de la multiplication des
catastrophes climatiques dans
l'aménagement des villes et des villages
ce sera notre débat avant je vous
propose cet extrait d'un reportage long
format tournée dans la vallée de la roya
c'était six mois après le drame il est
signé jonathan du prix yeahs c'est dans
ce décor figé hors du temps que la roya
amorcé sa reconstruction
elle s'annonce difficile longue et
coûteuse et pour le moment à deux
vitesses
d'un côté les infrastructures lourdes
capte la majorité des financements la
départementale 62 04 et ses travaux
estimé à 450 millions d'euros ou la
ligne ter ni stand au moins 30 millions
mais derrière ces chantiers jugés
prioritaires des dizaines restent en
suspens chez les habitants obligés de se
tourner vers des bénévoles
voler au secours des sinistrés est
devenue l'obsession de wilfrid ben
ricour ce jour là près de fontan il
vient en aide à pierre roy avec sa femme
ce retraité de 80 ans à la santé fragile
habitat un mot très reculées pour y
accéder il faut marcher une heure sur ce
sentier de randonnée escarpé
excusez moi je vais vous doublez chef le
couple d'octogénaires est isolé depuis
des mois faute de chemins carrossables
pour rejoindre le village le plus proche
nous avons deux pistes mais après les
dea tempête alex cette piste est restée
impraticable il y avait des
rami de ahmed à 80 cm de profondeur ce
qui fait que ce n'était plus du tout
praticable avec un véhicule quel qu'il
soit même un 4/4 impraticable
[Applaudissements]
s'il n'y avait pas des gens comme ça je
crois que dans toute la vallée après ça
les gens qui sont retrouvés avec des
maisons
empire et pleine de boue en sable et
jusque on pressent que toi j'irai dire
faut dire que ces gens là on devrait
terriblement terriblement pour aider
tout ce qui était sinistrée
parce que sinon
je veux pas critiquer mais
la difficile reconstruction et puis les
questions qui se pose finalement un peu
partout dans notre pays dans les zones
inondables lorsqu'il ya des projets de
d'aménagement de réaménagement comment
construire en tenant compte de ces
épisodes climatiques de plus en plus
violents on en débat avec françoise
vimeu bonsoir vous êtes climatologues
directrice de recherche à l'institut de
recherche pour le développement
arnaud gossement bonsoir vous êtes
avocat spécialiste du droit de
l'environnement l'un des avocats engagés
dans le procès dit de l' affaire du
siècle pour contraindre arnaud et agir
alors non bon d'accord on va donner une
nouvelle info voilà voilà ça m'arrive je
pense la première fois depuis le début
de la saison que j'ai une mauvaise info
sur l'un des invités je m'en excuse
platement voilà écouté au moins c'est
clair eric daniels lacombe bonsoir à
vous j'espère que j'ai pas d'erreur vous
avez conçu à romorantin en sologne un
quartier résistant aux crues vous venez
de remporter un appel d'offres sur le
réaménagement justement des vallées
ravagé par la tempête alex et puis avec
nous en visioconférence xavier pelletier
qui est préfet délégué chargé de la
reconstruction des vallées bonsoir
monsieur le préfet je commence avec vous
peut-être pour faire un point de
situation j'espère que vous m'entendez
bien un an après combien de sinistrés
recensés et indemnisés
bonsoir je m'excuse je n'ai pas entendu
votre question parce que j'ai eu une
petite interférences par pose combien de
sinistrés recensés et indemniser
aujourd'hui
alors les compagnies d'assurances estime
qu'il y à 3006 13000 sinistre et que les
indemnisations représenteront un coût de
217 millions d'euros à ce stade il y à
92 % des sinistres et particuliers qui
ont reçu un premier versement et 89 %
pour les entreprises
donc ça c'est le bilan à date il ya 420
bien immobilier si je ne me trompe qui
ne peuvent pas être réhabilité ça veut
dire quoi pour les familles ou son où
sont-elles qu'est ce que l'état a prévu
pour elle
pour être précis ce sont 420 biens qui
sont éligibles au fonds barnier et dans
ses 420 bien vous avez 480 maisons qui
ont été totalement détruites
les habitants qui était évidemment logés
dans ces maisons ont été évacuées et
sont relogés pour l'instant donc nous
sommes à peu près sur
800 personnes qui sont toujours logés
par le conseil départemental des alpes
maritimes dans la métropole nice côte
d'azur par le ccas de menton donc c'est
encore effectivement beaucoup de deux
personnes tout simplement parce que leur
maison sont exposés au risque est que
ces biens ont pour vocation d'être
acquis à l'amiable
les propriétaires recevront une
indemnisation et les biens seront en
détruit
eric daniels la conversion rester avec
nous évidemment monsieur monsieur le
préfet vous n'êtes pas c'est je crois un
an à mandelieu c'est ça oui j'ai peur
d'eux
vous le voyez dans mes yeux c'est ça ils
sont dans quel dans quel état d'esprit
les habitants de cette vallée est ce
qu'ils disent qu'ils sont dans encore
dans un an après voyez dans la crainte
d'un autre d'un autre événement d'une de
nouvelles intempéries bioland comment
voulez alors un an après le drame ce que
vient de raconter xavier pelletier je
pense que c'est terrible pour les
populations et je pense en même temps
que l' architecture peut aider allait
enfin les aider à devenir adaptés à ces
situations donc je pense que ça c'est
quelque chose d'important à mandelieu
c'est ce qu'on a fait mais quand j'ai
rencontré le maire l'an denier sénégal
du autant en fait il a été touché lui sa
ville pratiquement détruite en 2015
s'était à nouveau en 2019 et il était
tellement inquiète d'une situation qui
pouvait recommencer qui m'a appelé avec
les services d'ailleurs de l'état et
depuis un an on essaye de laisser plus
de place à la rivière et on vient de
faire quelque chose d'assez formidable
c'est qu'on a trouvé une vingtaine
d'hectares qui appartenait au groupe
casino donc ça a été un an de
négociations pour qu'enfin on puisse
calmer la rivière maîtres en réduction
de vulnérabilité là la ville et réduire
comme ça une vulnérabilité c'est
permettre aussi à la ville d'exister
c'est à dire que le géant casino va
pouvoir se métamorphoser que les
quartiers juste en dessous vont pouvoir
reprendre vie et donc cette situation là
on en est ravi mais elle est difficile
au moment même de la catastrophe comme
vous le disiez je viens d'être choisi
par l'équipe de xavier pelletier et de
la ddt pour aider à réparer ou
reconstruire les vallées les deux
vésubie et ruia et je m'attends à des
difficultés réelles et c'est pour ça que
j'ai inventé une méthode qui est je fais
une journée un dessin et je vais passer
une journée avec les gens pour qu'ils le
critique c'est exactement comme votre
émission on cherche un sens public à la
mise en place d'une nouvelle
architecture ou d'une nouvelle
organisation de la vie donc remporté
l'adhésion du public avant de ceux avant
de se lancer c'est ça la démarche jeu
parce que ce pas ce que c'est il ya un
nouveau un autre bouleversement qui ce
qui se rajoute à celui de la catastrophe
c'est ce que vous êtes en train de
brouiller les quais jeu je pense que si
vous regardez les populations
après les catastrophes soient elles
pensent que la catastrophe a été
tellement incroyable qu'elle reviendra
plus jamais soit on est dans le système
où il faudrait revenir à l'état
antérieur avec de temps en temps des
d'efforts dénis et finalement moi ce que
je propose c'est une adaptation par
petites touches c'est à dire vous le
disiez je me suis d'abord entraînés à
construire un quartier à romorantin qui
a résisté à une crue plus que centrale
mais c'était une crue lente on m'a dit
c'est très facile à mandelieu ça fait un
an qu'on travaille à un dessin il
pensait à des dj proposer des rizières
il pensait à bloquer l'eau j'ai permis
qu'elle continue et qu'elle rejoigne la
méditerranée pour qu'elles soient moins
méchante et on m'a dit c'est une crue
rapide c'est un peu plus difficile et
dans les vallées je vous emmènerai si
vous voulez c'est très difficile parce
que ce sont des crues torrentielles et
c'est même plus de l'eau c'est ce qu'on
appelle du transport solide donc je suis
en train de faire des progrès sur le
transport solidaire que l'eau entraîne
des rochers qui font de temps en temps
la taille de votre studio est le
monsieur le disait très bien mais
effectivement qui rentre dans la maison
et et qu'il la casse mais le seul à
penser ses solutions par des fous que
vous soyez là seul homme alors peut-être
que vous êtes génial je sais pas je me
débats mais non elle a pensé ces
solutions je suis d'abord pas seul
puisque la démarche c'est qu'on soit en
coproduction et les assemblées que je
fabrique on y va comme ça toutes les
trois semaines c'est tous les gens qui
sont pas d'accord entre eux par exemple
à mandelieu il ya la ville et l'agglo
vous savez que la ville est responsable
de sa ville mais l'agglo est responsable
du bassin versant il ya les gens de
marseille qui représente la nature qui
veulent la sanctuarisés et puis à des
gens qui aiment la nature au sens de la
biodiversité et puis il ya le maire qui
veut plus de place pour la rivière mais
malheureusement les terrains ne lui
appartiennent pas donc un an avec casino
sur des terrains qu'ils pensaient encore
il ya six mois constructible au bord de
la méditerranée
quand les préfets leur dise ça sera plus
constructive mais en plus vous devez les
céder à la ville à un prix dont je
reparlerai pas ce soir parce que ça fait
de fort débat donc il n'y a rien de
génial je pense que ce sont des formes
de diplomatie inventive tout à fait
intéressante à mettre en place je
voudrais qu'on revienne sur ce qui s'est
passé il ya enfants soient mieux c'est
quoi c'est la conjonction de plusieurs
phénomènes climatiques c'est ça
exactement en fait ce qui s'est passé
c'est qu'on avait une forte tempête sur
l'océan atlantique
et puis en même temps on avait un
épisode méditerranéen qui était en train
de se développer et donc cette tempête
alex a n'est pas elle qui a frappé
directement le littoral du sud de la
france mais elle a favorisé en fait cet
épisode méditerranéen les nuls
intensifiée et ça a permis une entrée
très rapide très brutale en fait d'air
chaud et humide en provenance de la mer
méditerranée et ses terres en fête s'est
confronté à de l'air froid plus en
altitude et toute l'eau qui a été
contenue dans l'atmosphère est bien est
retombé très brutalement sur un temps
très courant et on met effectivement
confrontée à une multiplication là il
n'y a pas de débat scientifique une
multiplication d'épisodes climatiques
plus violents alors en fait on voit très
bien et le rapport du giec qui est sorti
début août le rappelle le réchauffement
de l'atmosphère et des océans vient
exacerber des événements extrêmes que ce
soit des événements depuis torrentielles
des sécheresses ou des vagues de chaleur
et ça vient intensifié ces événements
mais ça vient aussi multiplier leur
probabilité d'occurrence et en
particulier sa touche effectivement fin
ça concerne les événements méditerranéen
arnaud gossement quelles leçons vous
tiré de cette ce qui s'est passé dans
les vallées des alpes-maritimes il ya un
an sur le plan juridique de l'action
jury des jeux le plan juridique ce qui
est frappant c'est que on a un droit qui
est surtout axée sur la prévention de
ces risques qu'on qualifie de risques
naturels et françoise il me l'a bien
expliqué si risques naturels ne sont
plus si naturel que ça ils ont été
accélérés intensifier x l'action de
l'homme ces changements climatiques donc
déjà il va faire passer d'un droit des
risques naturels à l'endroit des risques
générés par le changement climatique
et puis même cette prévention ne marche
pas très bien dans la vallée de la roya
par exemple certaines communes ne savait
pas qu'elle était soumise à un risque
majeur d'inondation et assure-t-on
d'habitants notamment à breil-sur-roya
ont découvert effectivement dans ce plan
eh bien il n'était pas classé à risques
par rapport à un risque de crue et puis
la deuxième chose qui est très
importante et je rebondis sur ce que
vous venez de dire c'est que notre droit
il est surtout axée sur la prévention
qui ne marche pas toujours très bien et
pas tellement sur l'adaptation ça
commence à changer mais sur tout le
littoral il va falloir s'adapter
s'adapter c'est parfois exproprier des
gens vous avez tous vu vous savez cette
résidence le signal qui se trouve en
bord de mer le trait de côte recul est
donc cette résidence va s'effondrer un
jour ou l'autre il faut pouvoir on est
alors c'est sur cette côte là
effectivement skis très intéressant
c'est que ses habitants ont acheté leur
maison à une époque où la mer était
beaucoup plus loin ils l'ont vu se
rapprocher ces eux-mêmes qu'ils
souhaitaient est exproprié à la fin et
puis à mandelieu c'est un exemple dont
on parle beaucoup parce que il est
extraordinaire mais en même temps il est
un peu trop épisode aujourd'hui mon dieu
c'est typiquement la commune que je
connais très bien sur laquelle on à
urbaniser à urbaniser au lendemain
d'assurance guerre mondiale ces cours
d'eau qui se jette dans la mer ont été
recouverts d'habitation est aujourd'hui
effectivement on a une municipalité
alors je sais pas si c'est parce qu'ils
n'ont pas le choix parce que les
habitants les ont prévenus ce sera à
vous nous dire mais qui souhaite
s'adapter c'est à dire non pas à dominer
la nature mais s'adapter à ce que la
nature a déjà fait et les décisions qui
sont prises par ce maire c'est plutôt
que de valoriser je pense que ce terrain
elle est très très cher du groupe casino
moi je les ai vus en friche pendant des
décennies et bien aujourd'hui
effectivement vous développez du
maraîchage vous développez une zone de
crues qui pourra éponger la crue du rio
qui se trouve juste à côté donc on est
en train de s'adapter de penser
adaptation au changement climatique
pourquoi parce que changement climatique
avant se disait c'est demain aujourd'hui
on comprend que c'est aujourd'hui en r2
dont il ya presque on est à la remorque
du changement climatique c'est bien le
problème c'est que ça arrivait donc on
crée des solutions après mais est-ce que
c'est durable est ce que parce que
madame vous nous dites que ça va revenir
est-ce que ça revenir plus fort est ce
que vos solutions être suffisamment
résistante cc on comprends l'angoissé
des populations sur place à non sur la
résistance est sur le retour
l'adaptation va aussi passer par une
accélération du phénomène
et une intensification des phénomènes
vous dites il faut ça sert à rien
d'essayer de construire des
infrastructures
c'est pas forcément la solution des
digues de plus en plus grande etc c'est
vrai quand je fais ces petits dessins en
séance mais pratiquement en séance j'ai
trois modes de tension comme ça et c'est
vraiment ce que je proposerai à xavier
pelletier pour les pour les vallées
parce que bien les maires vous imaginez
bien qu'ils ont perdu beaucoup de
surfaces ils sont en plus dans des
endroits encaissés et donc la question
de la surface ou celle du foncier s'ils
voulaient traduisez en termes de
propriété va être importante on a trois
systèmes de curseur le premier c est ce
qu on choisit des protections
artificielle qu'on a appelé des digues
ou des régulation naturelle je pense que
ce débat-là peut occuper une assemblée
pendant plusieurs semaines regardez la
meuse qui a traversé l'europe elle a
abîmé la belgique elle a abîmé
l'allemagne et elle n'a pas abîmé la
hollande et était en langue c'est normal
parce qu'ils ont mis en place un
programme qui s'appelle laisser plus de
place à la rivière et donc pourtant les
hollande avec avait appris à construire
les polders maintenant les démonte et
rendent les surfaces à la mer voyez la
terre à la mer et ça c'est des
phénomènes d'évaluation très important
mais ça va être une des grandes
questions que vous aviez pelletier
connaît bien entre les gens qui voudront
une protection pour retrouver finalement
la situation d'hier ou de se dire
finalement qu'est ce qu'on fait est
qu'elle est le curseur avec lequel on
donne de la place à la rivière la
deuxième question qui va être formidable
a arbitré c'est pour ça que je reviens
toujours sur le sens public c'est pas
moins excellent arbitrage fait des
dessins pour que les arbitrages fois
pris c'est la question de est ce qu'on
considère la nature comme un fléau ou
est-ce qu'on engage une convivialité
avec elle et c'est difficile au
lendemain d'une catastrophe surtout
quand il ya eu des décès de se dire que
c'est pas un fléau et ben je continue à
penser que la nature et je fais des
projets comme sage inaugure une maison
des jeunes et de la culture on a ouvert
les murs enlever les écluses rendu le
rez-de-chaussée transparent et on
apprend aux gamins de cette maison à
comprendre deviner la rivière et le
dernier point c'est qu'à chaque fois
qu'il ya une catastrophe on nous dit les
architectes vous n'êtes pas très doué
faites nous des maisons plus solides
appuis solides et je dis surtout pas et
je dis mais si on fait des maisons plus
étanche on se coupe de qui de là nature
donc expliquer moi si je suis étanche et
je suis coupé de la nature vous voudriez
que le lendemain je la comprenne que je
sache deviner une avalanche à un endroit
une coulée un endroit une crue donc il
faut trouver un équilibre entre ce que
j'appelle un abri et un ouvert mais moi
j'ai des enfants que j'ai élevé à paris
s'il pleut le sort pas donc elles ne
seront pas faire vous voyez ce que je
veux dire mais il faut mentionner les
inscrits mais je voudrais bien de
tourner justement vers des pelletiers
parce que la ccc on est au coeur de
votre mission monsieur le monsieur le
préfet et c'est vrai que en entendant
mairie d'asnières la cour jeudi il faut
qu'on change totalement notre façon de
penser que comment vous percevez ça se
fait ce changement de logiciel
ce que vient de dire à éric denudt la
cambe est très intéressant et je partage
totalement dire tout intervenant parce
que je dis dans les vallées c'est qu'on
ne reconstruira pas contre lomé avec
l'eau ça signifie trois choses c'est que
quand on a affaire à des crues
torrentielles voir des laves
torrentielles
on ne cherche pas à endiguer on ne
cherche pas à contraindre l'écoulement
de l'eau dans ces bassins versants on
prend en considération trois facteurs
très importants en citant pour redonne
de la largeur aux rivières ont fait en
sorte de ménager des zones d'expansion
pour que la rivière puissent consommer
son énergie déposé ces matériaux on
essaye de faire sauter les verrous
hydraulique parce qu'on sait que les
verrous hydrauliques les rétrécissements
génère des accélérations hydraulique et
quand on a des manifestations avec
effectivement des matériaux qui viennent
impacter les infrastructures impacté les
maisons c'est extrêmement violent et
ensuite on reconstruit et de façon
résiliente alors c'est le premier
élément évidemment à prendre en
considération on a pris beaucoup de
temps
localement pour analyser décortiquer ce
qui s'était passé les 2 et 3 octobre
pour essayer de comprendre l'événement
pour essayer de se projeter et salwar
demain et moi je partage tout à fait
léser les avis des experts évidemment je
suis pas spécialiste mais on aura à
nouveau des manifestations
météorologiques violentes donc quand on
retrouve au construit des
infrastructures quand on remet les ponts
avaient en fait attention de remettre
les ponts dans le flux hydraulique aux
rallonges et tabliers on fortifie les
culés de part et d'autre des rives ont
fait en sorte d'avoir moins darche tout
quand on a des piliers ont fait en sorte
qu'ils soient hydrodynamique remettra
dans la roya des ponts avec 100 à 100
clients pour effectivement faciliter les
mouvements hydraulique et ça on explique
ça aux gens organisent régulièrement des
réunions d'information avec les
sinistrés pour leur faire comprendre
pour faire de la pédagogie il faut
vraiment donner à voir aux gens le
risque bien l'éclairer expliqué on a une
chance inouïe en france on a un régime
de catastrophes naturelles avec un fonds
de prévention des risques naturels
majeurs communément appelé fonds barnier
qui permet finalement de tirer tous les
enseignements d'un événement comme celui
qu'on a vécu ici on ne reconstruit pas
dans les zones de risque ça c'est
évident et quand on a des maisons qui
sont exposés au risque eh bien on met en
oeuvre le fonds barnier on acquiert ces
maisons
les gens sont indemnisés ils peuvent
année seront légers dans des zones à la
marine l'aléa c'est extrêmement
importante et vous le disiez tous il
faut apprendre à vivre avec les risques
quand on regarde la carte des risques
dans les vallées et bien c'est une
exposition plus torrentielles au lave
torrentielle aux avalanches aux chutes
de blocs aux affaissements de terrain je
crois qu'on a tous les le tout le panel
et il ya aussi un risque sismique dans
les alpes maritimes comme vous le savez
je crois qu'on est toute l'année lui
tout le panel des risques xavier
pelletier jouer que qu'on revoie
ensemble une séquence vous êtes partie
prenante c'est un autre extrait du
reportage long format qu'on a vu en
ouverture de ce de ce débat donc les
équipes de public sénat sont retournés
dans les vallées sinistrées c'était il
ya 6 mois donc six mois après la
catastrophe vous êtes apostrophé par les
habitants regarder
mais je comprenais pas ce que
2011 on a mis notre sens là dedans notre
fatigue notre main on a tous fait nos
mains et on nous annonce qu'on va tout
perdre pour une histoire d'enrochement
est ce qu'on a en soi une rivière de 15
mai de l'aja c'est pas ça le sujet le
sujet c'est que demain c'est un
événement dramatique se reproduisait que
vous ne perdiez pas la vie parce que je
vous dis franchement moi je vous dis
franchement j'ai dit à mon mari ce matin
quand on m'a annoncé ça je préfère dans
la maison il partirait que la maison
avait pelletier voilà on est on est
vraiment au coeur de la démonstration
qu'on fait les les uns et les autres et
j'imagine que la situation n'a pas
beaucoup changé en six mois
alors c'est vrai que on a beaucoup de
traumatismes encore il ya encore
beaucoup de douleur il ya des deuils à
beaucoup d'angoissé moi je rencontre
régulièrement les médecins notamment le
responsable de la maison de santé de la
roya qui me dit très régulièrement
voilà les enfants quand il se met à
pleuvoir pour le voir se mettre à
pleurer on suit à peu près mille sept
cents personnes qui sont extrêmement
fragiles alors là le cas qu'on a vu à
l'image effectivement c'est une maison
qui aujourd'hui est fortement exposé aux
risques puisqu'il ya eu un exaucement du
lit de la rivière de plus de 10 mètres
en fait la maison est aujourd'hui en
dessous du niveau du lit la rivière dans
quelle est très exposé il faut faire la
pédagogie il faut essayer de trouver des
solutions en l'occurrence pour cette
famille on va faire des divisions de
parcelles puisque les propriétaires ou
une grande parcelle on va essayer de
reconstruire sur le haut de la parcelle
qui est à l'abri de l'aller à l'abri du
risque mais là on ne voit pas forcément
très bien sur l'image mais la maison
effectivement il suffirait d'une dinde
d'intempéries même pas forcément d'une
grande intensité pour qu'elle soit très
fortement exposés avec une mobilisation
très importante de matériaux et le
risque effectivement ces longues
rarement la maison c'est à dire que la
maison soit totalement noyé sous les
pierres et sous les roches
merci de ceux de ce témoignage rester
avec nous on va on va élargir sur le
risque politique
laetitia cloud pas parce que on peut
dire qu'une catastrophe puis à des
exemples dans le passé une catastrophe
climatique mal géré ça peut être
potentiellement dévastateurs pour
l'exécutif pour le pouvoir en place oui
on le voit c'est une illustration
parfaite de ce qu'on appelle la
communication de crise parce que c'est
une crise voilà une catastrophe comme
celle là le politique arrive et doit
parer à l'urgence l'urgence monsieur
c'est le traumatisme immédiat mais aussi
une exigence de protection or on adore
critiquer l'état en france mais on a
absolument besoin de l'état aussi l'état
protecteur et l'homme politique incarne
l'état donc bien sûr que un déplacement
après une catastrophe est vraiment
primordiale et il y à un contre exemple
absolu en la matière en 2001 c'est le
premier ministre lionel jospin qui se
déplace à habile après et des
innovations de la somme il ya une petite
rumeur qui court depuis quelques
semaines qui dit qu'en fait la crue
auraient été
commandités biais de paris pour voulu
sauver paris et on a sacré la rue ou
délégations étaient attendus pour les
jeux olympiques ça c'est le petit
contexte historique et on aurait dévié
pour finalement épargné paris et on
aurait finalement landes et la somme et
alors là lionel jospin arrive et va au
contact des sinistrés je vous propose de
regarder
on tousse vous vous rendez pas compte
ses 20 ans de notre vie nous l'a confié
au père des combats mais
je suis au courant
et on voit tout comme le diable devait
tant partir comme ça on s'en fiche
alors si on essaie de comparer les deux
époques et notamment la réaction de
l'exécutif juste avec lionel jospin
devant la détresse de cette femme par
exemple ils avaient apposé à froid
technocratique et aucune empathie en
balayant d'un revers de main cette cette
rumeur ensuite ce qui s'est passé
ensuite dans le sud de la france avec
l'exécutif macron castex donc là on
revient il ya un an hier jean castex qui
se déplacent tout de suite mais il reste
à nice et c'est vrai qu'on se dit
pourquoi il ne va pas directement sur
les lieux de la catastrophe
c'est parce que en fait c'est le
président de la république qui a décidé
de prendre cette communication en main
et c'est lui c'est emmanuel macron qui
va au contact des sinistrés et là c'est
vraiment l'exemple inverse de lionel
jospin c'est à dire qu'ils touchent les
gens ça ils aiment ça il va au contact
le président il va toucher les sinistrés
ça nous semble peut-être accessoires
mais quand on est dans la situation de
ces gens qui viennent d'être touchées
qui ont peut-être perdu des proches
effectivement ce contact humain incarnez
encore une fois par le chef de l'état
est primordial ensuite viendront dans la
dans la minute qui suit les annonces
pour les mesures d' aide de secours etc
des choses concrètes pour la population
mais cette communication qui finalement
et non verbale est primordial je
voudrais qu'on aille au delà donc ça se
terrant l'aspect de la communication
politique un agacement sur l'aspect jeu
il dit que c'est vrai que pendant des
années
c'était plutôt localement qu'on se
posait les questions de des conséquences
en parlant du plan d'occupation des sols
de
des zones inondables des permis de
construire etc c'était localement qu'on
se disait on cherche des responsables on
cherche des coupables maintenant il ya
effectivement un mouvement pour aller
plus haut pour mettre en cause l'état
pour faire pression pour l'état sur
l'état oui c'est très juste un ce que
vous venez de dire il ya un paradoxe à
la fois il ya une demande des tas de
protection qui est très forte et en même
temps ces injonctions contradictoires
une accusation de détail mise en
accusation de l'état qui n'en feraient
pas assez qu'ils ne seraient pas assez
dans la protection dans le secours
effectivement vous faites référence à ce
qu'on appelle la sphère du siècle c'est
un recours qui a été déposée par
plusieurs associations de défense de
l'environnement dont greenpeace devant
le tribunal misrati de paris une commune
également à déposer un recours la
commune de grande synthe qui est aussi
une commune littorale qui s'estime à
juste titre exposés aux risques de
changement climatique notamment au recul
du trait de côte et ses recours il y en
a beaucoup dans le monde mais ces deux
recours déposés en france ont grosso
modo chi simplifie pour objet de faire
reconnaître la responsabilité de l'état
dans l'aggravation du changement
climatique alors c'est vrai que le trim
illustratif de paris en février a déjà
reconnu une faute de la part de l'état
une carence fautive des tâches fixe des
engagements de réduction des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre ne les tient pas
par la suite quand on dit l'état ce
n'est pas que le gouvernement bien
entendu c'est l'état ça dépasse le
gouvernement c'est l'appareil
administratif mais aussi les élus voir
la population ne respecte pas ses
engagements et la question c'est
qu'est-ce que peut le juger en face de
ça et c'est là où le cirque cours ne
font pas évidemment au delà de ce que de
ce que certains experts c'est à dire que
le juge se borne à constater cette faute
est ensuite à demander à l'état d'en
faire plus en terme de mesures de
décrets et deux mesures qui seront
prises malheureusement le jus ce n'est
pas celui qui va sauver la planète ni le
climat et on voit aussi que c'est au
niveau local comme effectivement on sait
qu'une fine j'y reviens que des
initiatives exemplaires sont prises par
des élus locaux c'est ça qui me donnent
beaucoup plus confiance il faut un
niveau étatique bien entendu mais ce qui
est fait concrètement sur le terrain
l'urbanisme l'aménagement du territoire
la densification des villes toutes ces
choses là sont du ressort des élus
locaux on oublie trop souvent qu'en
matière environnementale les deux
principaux décisionnaires c'est l'europe
d'une part qui est à l'origine de la
plupart des objectifs principes du droit
de l'environnement et puis ensuite ce
sont les collectivités territoriales
décentralisation oblige elles ont des
responsabilités en matière
environnementale d'urbanisme très très
important alors justement partie parlé
du rôle des sénateurs j'invite quentin
calme et me rejoindre sur la question
quand un rebond soir de l'indemnisation
des catastrophes naturelles oui c'est un
sujet qui va s'arrêter bientôt en séance
un même le 21 octobre très précisément
les parlementaires les sénateurs et les
députés qui travaillent sur ce sujet
depuis de nombreuses années on a retenu
quelques chiffres d'ailleurs dans leur
rapport parlementaire de 2019 au
sénateur regarder dans ce rapport on
notait qu un français sur quatre est
exposée aux risques d'inondation et que
presque toutes les communes en france
ont été touchés par une catastrophe
naturelle depuis 1982 date de la
dernière loi sur le sujet ce qui pousse
donc ses députés et sénateurs à ce
plancher à nouveau sur le sujet en
séance l'idée principale d'un texte donc
qu'arrive en octobre c'est un crédit
d'impôt pour la prévention des aléas
climatiques vont être aux particuliers
de déduire de leurs impôts le coût des
travaux oui le parlement veut aussi
rallonger les certain délai pour pouvoir
faire jouer son assurance est exactement
tout à fait notamment face aux
conséquences liées à la sécheresse peut
être intérêt ce que vous avez le moins
évoqué pour l'instant sur ce plateau
mais parce qu'on voit rarement en fait
immédiatement les conséquences de la
sécheresse sur sa maison après un
épisode de canicule le texte prévoit
donc de rallonger les délais pour saisir
son assureur car parfois après plusieurs
années qu'on voit et des fissures
apparaître sur les murs de sa maison la
proposition de loi qui est kényan
octobre voiliers qui prévoit aussi de
pouvoir faire indemniser par les
assureurs et les frais de relogement en
cas de catastrophe naturelle et dernier
pan du texte les parlementaires veulent
le mieux encadrer la reconnaissance même
de l'état de catastrophe naturelle les
sénateurs avaient jugé cette procédure
peu transparente alors désormais si
cette loi est adoptée les élus locaux
pourront faire appel d'une décision
défavorable d'un arrêté d'état de
catastrophe naturelle et enfin la
proposition de loi met en place un
délégué auprès du préfet en charge de
cette reconnaissance merci quentin voilà
dans cette émission on a chaque jour un
journaliste de la rédaction de public
sénat qui intervient qui fait un zoom
sur un point très très factuelle
françoise vie me comment est-ce qu'on
peut évaluer quand il ya une catastrophe
climatique ce qui est imputable ou non à
l'activité eux mêmes à ce qu'est ce que
vous avez les outils pour le faire oui
alors on a on a des outils en fait on
fait ses études qu'on appelle des études
d'attribution elles prennent
généralement aujourd'hui 3 4 semaines et
en fait quand il ya un événement extrême
que ce soit une vague de chaleur une
sécheresse ou une pluie torrentielle
on regarde si cet événement aurait pu
avoir lieu dans un climat non modifiées
par l'homme donc en fait on fait une
simulation climatique dans laquelle on
enlève le surplus de gaz à effet de
serre qui a été émis dans l'atmosphère
par les activités humaines ont fait
tourner sur plusieurs siècles et on
regarde si on voit ce genre d'événement
alors par exemple pour les inondations
qui ont lieu en allemagne au mois de
juillet eh bien on a eu ces études
d'attribution qui ont été réalisés et
qui ont montré qu'en fait le changement
climatique est venu à graffer cette
situation météorologique qui est
classique par ailleurs qu'on avait déjà
connu et en fait c'est venu aggraver par
le cumul des précipitations est ce qu'on
voit dans les événements extrêmes de
pluies torrentielles s'est pas tant le
fait que la probabilité d'occurrence va
augmenter c'est le fait que les cumuls
vont être de plus en plus important par
exemple si par malheur nous allions sur
un réchauffement qui atteindrait 4
degrés à la fin du siècle on sait que
pour les évènements depuis torrentielles
on pourrait avoir 30% en plus depuis
alors je vous propose un autre document
pour avancer dans la question de la
reconstruction et des choix que l'on
peut faire on a on a décidé avec la
rédaction de public sénat de retourner à
vaison-la-romaine vaison-la-romaine
souvenez vous c'était le 22 septembre
1992 la crue de nouvelles qui avait
provoqué la mort de 32 personnes
jonathan du prix est
difficile de le croire 29 ans après ce
parc de loisirs arboré et est l'un des
endroits les plus touchés lors de la
catastrophe de vaison la romaine
claude haut était maire en 1992 ses
souvenirs sont intacts c'est un quartier
qui était très vivant puisqu'il avait à
l'époque
un supermarché quelques commerces autour
et surtout
une cinquantaine d'habitations qui est
qui qui représentait l'ensemble de ceux
de ce terrain que l'on voit autour de
nous et tout cela a été bien entendu
rasé détruits et
pour laisser la place à cet espace
à voir tout ça c'est à dire
c'était obligé pour l'ancien maire c'est
la réalisation la plus symbolique de son
mandat à quelques mètres d'une stèle en
hommage aux victimes ce lieu endeuillées
a finalement retrouvé la vie
ce qui s'est passé me rend toujours
triste autant devoir après l'utilisation
que les jeunes enfants de
la vie a repris ses droits mais au prix
d'un lourd endettement dont sort à peine
la commune en cause les travaux
titanesques menée notamment sur les
berges de l'ouvèze rendues
inconstructibles
certaines sont devenues des parkings
submersible en cas de nouvelles crues
car malgré ces aménagements la rivière
est toujours surveillée comme le lait
sur le feu audrey ceccaldi dirige le
syndicat de l'ouvèze provençal avec son
équipe c'est elle qui est chargée de la
prévention des inondations et de
l'entretien du cours d'eau pour le
compte de 49 communes on va couper les
arbres qui sont dp récent qui penche
trop dans la rivière pour éviter qu'il
tombe dans l'eau et qui viennent bloquer
les ponts on vient suite aux crues faire
des travaux de désensablement donc si
malgré tout et on a des orges deux ponts
qui ont été un peu bouché vent vient de
désobstruer immédiatement et puis on
vient sur ce qu'on appelle des
opérations de scarification sur les
bancs de galles et on vient les gratter
pour qu'ils puissent être être
remobilise
à la prochaine crue et donc permettre
aux cours d'eau de garder ça râle
largeur originel de son côté la ville
assure être passé à autre chose mais la
menace reste prise très au sérieux au
gré des ans les élus ont mis en place un
arsenal préventif plan communal de
sauvegarde
sensibilisation des riverains aux
risques majeurs vaison-la-romaine doit
composer avec le risque climatique
est-ce qu'on est assez serein tout le
temps
je le souhaite vivement
peu plus jour arriver une nouvelle
catastrophe dont on ignore les
conséquences
mais je pense que le principal a été
fait porté par ses 150 mille touristes
annuels vaison la romaine a su panser
ses plaies et préfère ne plus regarder
en arrière hormis les 22 septembre où
des gerbes viennent toujours commémorer
la mémoire des 47 victimes
et c'est vrai que le bilan s'est aggravé
après le le bien de 32 morts c'était
c'était juste après la la catastrophe il
se trouve que moi j'étais à
vaison-la-romaine à l'époque je me
souviens que le seul pont qui avait tenu
c'était le pont moyen-âgeux et que
évidemment la polémique s'était sur la
question des permis de construire en
zone inondable à arnaud gossement il y
en a beaucoup malheureusement encore
aujourd'hui en france des lotissements
qui sont en zone inondable on va pas
tous les détruire pour pour faire ce qui
s'est passé là c'est quoi la solution
s'arrogeant la problématique vous avez
évoqué dans votre séquence précédente
avec lubrizol c'est à dire des
constructions industrielles ou
d'habitations qui sont là alors certes
le droit progresse y ait des nouvelles
exigences des nouvelles normes des
nouveaux plans mais les constructions
sont antérieures donc on ne peut pas
faire en sorte facilement de porter
atteinte au droit de propriété de ces
personnes qui ont acheté des maisons
s'étendre là qui ont obtenu des permis
de construire en toute légalité à une
époque où le droit était beaucoup moins
foisonnant et puis une époque où si on
n'avait pas la culture du risque 1 il ya
non seulement effectivement une erreur
de la part de l'état d'avoir ou des
mères parfois d'avoir délivrer ces
permis de construire mais il y aussi une
erreur de la part de certains habitants
d'avoir sous-évalué des risques
le reportage qu'on a vu tout à l'heure
ces scènes
d'accueil effectivement d'un haut
fonctionnaire avec des personnes qui ne
sont pas contentes parce qu'on va leur
interdire d'habiter au même endroit on
les a eus partout où il ya eu des
épisodes inondations à la faute-sur-mer
par exemple à la suite de la tempête
xynthia certains habitants qui se
trouvaient pourtant dans la cuvette avec
des maisons qui avait été submergé on
fait des recours contre des décisions de
l'état de rendre inconstructibles la
zone donc il ya aussi si vous me
permettez cette expression un peu
malheureuse mais une sorte de
schizophrénie de chacun où on est
conscients des risques mais on se dit
moi ça ne se passera pas pour moi moi ma
maison elle échappera à ça ça s'est
passé qu'une fois c'est exceptionnel ce
que nous disent les climatologues c'est
que personne n'est à l'abri un le
changement climatique c'est pas juste
dans les pays au delà des frontières
c'est chez nous ça va être de plus en
plus souvent de plus en plus violents et
ça concerne tout le monde et c'est ça un
petit peu cette culture du risque qui
nous manque aujourd'hui
eric daniels la comble dans le reportage
avec la question de l'endettement de la
ville pour pouvoir voilà reconstruire
tenir compte de ce qui s'était passé
refaire une zone voilà deux finalement
de loisirs autour de autour du fleuve
c'est moi ça me renvoie l'action de la
perte de valeur d'une zone après une
catastrophe est ce que finalement les
solutions que vous proposez ça pourrait
permettre d'inverser cette logique
j'espère parce qu'en fait vous avez cité
d'un mot les assureurs et je vois les
assureurs lâché un maximum de bien j'ai
travaillé pendant deux ans pour les
campings ils ont du mal à être assurés
si vous êtes aux états unis les maisons
seront plus assurées donc la question
c'est combien de dégâts et combien
d'investissement au départ et quand vous
dites qu'il faut retourner la situation
j'appelle ça des transformations
positives qu'est-ce qu'on aurait à
gagner à métamorphoser nos habitats nos
paysages avant même d'être touchés
n'oubliez pas si vous y mettez à vaison
la romaine qui avait un camping et une
zone d'activités qui sont passés
l'ensemble sous le pont donc là la
transformation positive c'est celle qui
éviterait les dégâts romorantin c'est
quand même 0 dégâts en 2016 quand il ya
la crue c'est green 900 millions de
l'autre côté du département dont ces
sommes-là sont à transformer qu'est ce
que c'est qu'une transformation positive
en très vite très vite le patron du
gauche de mandelieu il y là dans son
golf à chaque accident fait une
transformation positive en 2015 il vous
fait un accueil avec un très grand
bassin de rétention qui est la plus
belle fontaine en 2019 il fait un trou
bordés d'eau qui est qui est splendide
et là il vient de faire le plus grand
practice du monde où il attire les plus
grands spectateurs joueurs donc c'est ça
les transformations positives et là on
gagne de l'argent
puisque c'était votre question merci
beaucoup vous êtes interrompu parce
qu'effectivement c'est la face édition
de débat parce que oui mais c'est mon
site ou qui sont passionnants merci à
tous d'avoir participé demain dans
bonjour chez vous au riad monsigny
reçoit philippe martinez secrétaire
général de la cgt je vous donne
rendez-vous lundi sur public sénat